contemporary tripods are made from
aluminum tubes that have four different
diameters the tubes are Electra welded
and anodized for precision hardness and
durability a machine cuts the tubes to
the required lengths a press expands one
end of the D shaped tubes to keep the
smaller diameters in place a worker
inserts a tube into this machine it uses
a high precision laser to etch the
company's name into the aluminum the
laser process turns the etched aluminum
white a worker puts foam sleeves called
legwarmers on two of the tripods three
legs the sleeves allow photographers to
easily handle the legs and extreme
temperatures the worker uses a
pressurized air device to open the
sleeve then she inserts the leg
she uses a specialized machine to add
the top hinge color to the upper leg
section
the parts were designed to work together
and click neatly into place next she
applies the locking collars when a
photographer adjusts the legs the
locking colors will hold them in place
she threads a bolt through the collar
ends and adds a quick release lever to
the assembly then she fastens all the
components in place next she brings the
legs together to form the tripod she
positions the bottom of the Spyder
component on a specially designed
support mechanism she installs the legs
and capstan with the top of the spider
then she bolts everything in place
next a worker assembles the tripod head
she places plastic rings between the
three main parts to ensure smooth and
accurate adjustments she installs
levelling bubbles to help photographers
accurately position their cameras she
adds the upper plate and the adjustment
knobs the plate screws into the camera
which conveniently mounts onto the
tripod once the entire head assembly is
complete a worker carefully threads it
onto the tripod column the final step in
the assembly process is to slide the
column and head down through the
spreader a worker checks to ensure the
mechanism is working correctly then
tightens the locking knob
the Finnish tripod is lightweight
compact and durable it'll keep the
camera steady for anyone who wants to
take portraits profile architectural
features or capture panoramic landscapes